[Música]
y yo quiero momento hablar de economía
en directo américa de france a 24 y para
ello me acompaña una de mis mujeres
favoritas del programa àngel hablando
con daniela quiero aprovechar también
esta oportunidad como la hija rosa para
decir el orgulloso que estoy a trabajar
con una mujer esta profesionales y tan
buena onda y tan buenas mujeres y tan
buenas personas como ustedes hay tan
lindos raúl muchísimas gracias y
entonces algo tan lindo en mucho tiempo
hay daniela huilense le estoy diciendo
aquí al frente de todos los que nos
están viendo ahora y vamos a hablar
ahora economía de eso si rusia accidente
amenazan se amenazan mutuamente con la
energía aquí pues raúl lleva en eeuu y
occidente sus aliados occidentales días
enteros tratando de mirar si le van a
dejar de importar crudo a rusia pero
saben que no les conviene en el fondo
ahora es moscú el que amenaza con cortar
el principal gasoducto de rusia a
alemania que es el nord stream 1
escuchemos el informe
crecientes tensiones sobre la energía
rusa el lunes el vice primer ministro
ruso advirtió que una prohibición
occidental sobre el petróleo ruso sería
respondida con represalias incluyendo el
posible cierre del principal gasoducto
de rusia-alemania tenemos todo el
derecho a tomar una decisión coincidente
e imponer un embargo al bombeo de gas a
través del gasoducto nor sin uno la
invasión de ucrania ya ha llevado a
berlín a cancelar la apertura del nuevo
gasoducto nord stream 2 pero las
sanciones han librado hasta ahora en su
mayor parte al sector energético ruso
por temor a provocar una crisis de
suministro que desestabiliza las
economías occidentales
a medida que aumentan las víctimas eeuu
consideran prohibir las importaciones de
petróleo ruso vital fuente de ingresos
para moscú
el presidente no ha tomado ninguna
decisión en este momento de la
prohibición de importar petróleo de
rusia y esas discusiones están en curso
internamente y con nuestros homólogos y
socios and world sin embargo los países
europeos están dudando el continente
depende de rusia para el 40% de su gas
natural y casi un tercio de su petróleo
el precio del crudo brent de referencia
en europa ya se ha disparado a máximos
de 14 años en los últimos días
alcanzando los 139 dólares por barril y
los futuros del gas natural europeo han
batido récords de precios los analistas
del mercado creen que una prohibición
del petróleo ruso provocaría un
importante déficit mundial y podría
elevar los precios del crudo hasta 200
dólares por barril
danny y mientras alejada de rusia eeuu
se acerca a un ex socio comercial de
quién estamos hablando yo creo que usted
sabe quién estamos hablando y mira raúl
yo tengo una prima que ha sido
negociadora toda la vida y ella me dice
no peleé con sus socios comerciales no
se mira como que uno que le va mal pues
mire hubo una reunión el fin de semana
entre el presidente de venezuela nicolás
maduro y en una delegación de
diplomáticos estadounidenses la primera
reunión de alto nivel en dos años desde
que washington sancionó al país
prohibiendo la venta de crudo que
representaba el 96 por ciento de sus
ingresos y se rompieron lazos entre
estados unidos y venezuela escuchemos yo
ratifico
como le dije la delegación
toda nuestra voluntad
desde la diplomacia
desde el respeto
y desde la máxima
esperanza de un mundo mejor
y nosotros poder avanzar en una agenda
que permita el bienestar y la paz
de los pueblos de nuestro hemisferio de
nuestra región aunque no se puede decir
que propiamente de limaron asperezas
washington si está buscando un socio que
le permita cortar con rusia sin mayores
traumatismos y también probablemente
alejar a moscú de uno de sus principales
aliados en la región que es venezuela
quien sí dio pistas fue la secretaria de
prensa de la casa blanca jen psaki quien
afirmó que el propósito del viaje era
discutir una serie de temas incluida la
seguridad energética la dicotomía danny
entre la moral y el dinero en la plática
así es la plática siempre va a ganar un
importante insumo mundial dejó de
transarse en londres de que estamos
hablando and estamos hablando del níquel
que pues desde que inició la guerra los
compradores se han lanzado a negociarlo
y esto catapultado los precios pues si
un día antes de que estallara la guerra
una tonelada de níquel costaba un poco
más de 24 mil dólares en la bolsa de
metales de londres este martes llegó a
superar los 100 mil dólares por primera
vez en la historia casi duplicó su
precio en apenas una jornada porque es
tan importante el níquel danny
este es un metal crucial para la
fabricación de materiales industriales
como acero inoxidable y rusia- es clave
produce el 10% del níquel del mundo es
muy bueno para aleaciones es decir
cuando se juntan dos metales porque su
eficiencia ante la corrosión pues lo
hace ideal entonces es bastante
utilizado sobre todo raúl en la gran
industria como en hornos industriales
turbinas de aviones barcos inclusive hay
monedas o pilas recargables que son
fabricadas con nyc danny pues gracias
entonces por toda esta información
económica en el próximo bloque directo
américa hablamos de más repasamos infra
del día y también cómo están los
indicadores pasamos ahora a hablar de
deportes